[Music]
at bethesda game studios we love to
create experiences that through art and
technology
transport you we've brought that to many
worlds
but never to what's above us
when we look to the sky we wonder if
we're alone
what's out there what our future holds
in some ways since every element in each
of us is from the stars
we want to return
starfield is our first new universe in
over 25 years
it's a game we've dreamt of playing and
it's only now
that we have the hardware the technology
and the experience
to push our creative boundaries even
further
in it we invite you to join
constellation
the last group of space explorers it's a
next-generation role-playing game where
you'll be who you want
go where you want experience our stories
and forge your own
more than that star feels about hope our
shared humanity
and searching for the answers to life's
greatest mystery
we have a lot to share for the first
time we'll provide an inside look at the
inspiration and process behind starfield
we hope you'll join constellation and go
with us on the journey
as we craft our next epic
[Music]
you